il ya une rubrique dans cette émission
qui s'appelle costard de stars ou en
taille des costumes aux stars vous
promet d'être pas vous vexer
non seulement je me cache mais alors on
regarde le costard de stars
[Musique]
monsieur que pensez-vous de philippe
bouvard je n'aime pas beaucoup
à votre avis vieux croûtons c'est parce
qu'il est petit qu'il est agressif
j'en sais rien il n'est pas agressif la
taille n'a rien à voir là dedans ou
vieux débris les personnes petit ne sont
pas forcément agressive du tout pas du
tout a dit plus elles sont pas du tout
agressif pas forcément comme les autres
comme les grandes
nous avons trouvé agressif connard
vocabulaire un peu mais c'est pas grave
il y bouvard j'en ai pensé beaucoup de
choses et puis plus grand chose j'sais
pas pourquoi je sais pas j'ai regardé
quelques voix je trouve que c'est un
humour d'accord mais pas de grandes
volées à votre habit à votre habit
vieille peau c'est parce qu'il est petit
qu'il est agressif au alors s'envoler
une question très importante
il bougeait pas la journée non plus un
pardon des péchés vous de répondre oui
je messieurs que pensez-vous de philippe
bouvard du mal du mal beaucoup de mal
pourquoi ces longs sera long à dire
penser que c'est parce qu'il est petit
qu'il est agressif âge avait jamais
pensé qu'il était petit savais pas qu'il
était petit fait plausible qu'il répond
j'ai pas que ça à [ __ ] non plus il est
petit vous allez vous faire [ __ ]
votre avis via morue c'est parce qu'il
est petit qu'il est agressif
non rien à voir il va russe et pour lui
c'est pour moi c'est pour vous oh merci
on sait que c'est parce qu'il est petit
il est agressif grand con oui je pense
oui bah oui je pense mais bah ouais là
la preuve trouvé agressif
kollar ouais vous pensez que les petits
sont forcément agressive connard non
abruti
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou